Haley is with us in New York hi Haley
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show here
yeah hi how can I help
so I'm 17 and I'm about to head off to
college in a couple months and my own
I'm out of state to my school so was
acting like my scholarships and it comes
about socially and my parents
collectively make about 320 years give
or take and not to sound ungrateful
fight I knew from a young age that they
weren't going to contribute to anything
for college for me so I was wondering
how I would go about the federal loans
because we didn't qualify for any of the
student one your parents make three
hundred and twenty thousand dollars a
year and their plan for you is to go
into debt to go to college yeah I don't
think I need to be talking to you I
think I need to be talking to them
that's absurd I know my dad we've
discussed it a little bit and he's she
makes primarily most the money he makes
about 280 or 260 the thing is is they
just bought a second house last year and
they're older than most parents for
they're planning on retiring probably in
the next like seven to ten years so my
parents my mom is just like saving all
of her money for that rather than like
well that's sweet they bought a second
house so they can't afford to send their
kid to college yeah that's some
screwed-up value system see I won me I
should be talking to them instead of
talking to you Donna because I am NOT
going to tell you at 17 years old here
on the radio to go into debt to go to
college I think there's other stuff
going on here
and I know you've got your heart set on
that particular school and this
particular path
and your family is going to do what your
family is going to do but you called me
here on the air and asked me what I
would do I would challenge your parents
and it's not that it's not that you're
ungrateful I can't possibly imagine
making 320 thousand dollars a year not
sending my kid to school letting them go
into that to go to school I just I can't
imagine that that doesn't occur to me my
children are more important than my
second home
it just doesn't calculate well in my
value system so you probably need to sit
down and talk with them and get a
different understanding and you need to
get some other coaching in detail on how
you might head off to school a different
place where you can afford it without
student loans because I'm not going to
tell you to go into student loan debt
kiddo
it's the 30 year old version of you is
not going to like the 17 year old
version of you that made these decisions
but you're apparently making by yourself
as well which is also bad parenting on
your parents part they should be in
there helping you make decisions to not
go into student loan debt in addition to
helping you financially so that's what I
would tell you to do is get try to get
some help from some coaches some
counselors and your college choice and
where you can the cheapest place you can
go if you've got to pay for it yourself
and what kind of jobs you can line up
and what kind of scholarships you can
line up so that you can go to school
without going into debt